[Music]
in stranded news stranded waiting for
help oh I thought it was how you heard
in haunted house ghost me somebody help
me submitted by in Myanmar me amor my
love and estimated 10,000 people
restrained by the immediate shutdown of
iceland's Wow err [ __ ] budget
airlines you y'all [ __ ] Allegiant and
[ __ ] spirit oh [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you I have to fly Allegiant it's the
only one that goes directly to my
parents so I'm not gonna say thing about
that but [ __ ] Spirit Airlines what do we
do yak see wait am I gonna get sponsored
by them no not really no yeah wait you
like flying without being able to
recline I know no it's because it's the
only direct flight otherwise I have to
go stopover in Atlanta for a few hours
I'd rather do that no because I won our
flight then stop by Atlanta you don't
get delayed before you get on that plane
I haven't been delayed yet it's better
than spirit though we have to pay not to
have the airline attendants sneeze on
you to be in a certain section for that
mmm funny [ __ ] airline they go it's
$80 for the seat but $20 for the oxygen
$40 exactly to blink yep if you don't
you'll be fine [ __ ] ridiculous yeah I
think I took them the first I went to
Paris is dude took me to Paris I can't
take you to Paris like [ __ ] dope and
then I ended up on a [ __ ] like budget
airline he's taking a pair for free oh
[ __ ] I have better standards in that n8
yeah Dean we're talking about we Perry
Aeroflot yeah I think that was budget
otherwise I'm really sure but the food
was like still frozen when it came out
yeah a little disgusting why the [ __ ]
feeding you this is gross it was free
Gina oh [ __ ] she would rather have
stayed home and then looked at Paris
through her phone did you did he take
you to hostels in Paris no okay that'll
be pretty good welcome to Paris let's go
to the catacombs yeah music we're
sleeping under this bridge right that
feel the one thing I want to do I sleep
on her bridge yeah that one thing no the
catacomb what's the catacombs in Paris
oh it's like these underground tunnels
have a whole bunch of like line for your
villages and skulls of people that have
died because I think it was the plague
or something I haven't been there so I
don't know I've been there a completely
forgot about them
so it's whatever someone died in it like
a few years ago cuz it was a New Year's
party down there and she got lost in
there and then they finally found her
body she was like curled up she died how
long did she get Jesus Drummle like it's
like a great amazing she fell or
something no she's she's just like
starved to death in the [ __ ] what but
what why wouldn't you just keep
screaming for two days no she did in two
days no one found it was the weekend
[ __ ] crazy yeah cool let's go to the
catacombs death I don't want to go we'll
just have strings tied to each other
there you go dude I'm leaving Doritos
everywhere I go it's like a crunch my
way back stupid all the rats they're
French rats though if you drop American
bread be like oh no no he's not cheese
ranch bread the real [ __ ]
Wonderbread the [ __ ] French rents the
soxhlet yeah yeah they won't they won't
do a toy a snobby rats bo2 American rats
are judging French France's [ __ ] that's
right
if rats just had fluffy tails it would
be a difference I [ __ ] love rats well
what are those what's the rat that look
like rats but they're not rats in there
fluffy tails squirrels
maybe those chilis have long toes do
they are so soft I love them silicone
what if I gave it to you what if I give
it to you as a present I mean thank you
you know I will sell it for money
I wear that [ __ ] that's terrible what if
they all died of natural causes there
you go that's my business okay what if
it's like harvested humanely like you
know this ostrich leather bags all just
leather bags have like the bumps on them
how do you harvest those guys you mainly
know screaming oh my I refused to worry
you have like ostrich handbags because
what they do is that how they get those
bumps is they rip the feathers out while
they're still alive because the blood
coagulates under and then that's how
they make the bumps and when I heard
that I was like I'm never getting an
Austrian people look for those bumps
they like oh this one was in pain yeah
you should [ __ ] see the alligator for
years they skinned them alive why why
can't they kill their life there's third
the better quality of thing it's they
[ __ ] put a rubber band on their
mouths
and they're just going to town and these
ports it's [ __ ] I don't know that
they were alive because I seem to do it
when they're dead because they would
harvest the meat then they will use the
skin and sell the skin off there's
that's like cheaper get me sad let's
talk about why that stuff oh my got the
way my alligator pit boobs now those
those might look sick
Oh they've been amazing yeah I actually
kept the teeth autumn too did you all
right Wow Airlines collapsed and it just
stranded 10,000 morons ocean people you
know it's crazy when we're out there we
some people on the tours that we were
with they booked with Wow and they had
no way to get home oh they didn't even
get an email or nothing they found out
from the news media like the new sites
have to do what happened extra Hotel
nights oh yeah like there's this one
family from Michigan right they had to
leave on Friday and then the girl has
school or whatever so they they found
out because one of the tour guides when
we're doing a glacier walk they told us
like did you hear about while airlines
like they totally closed down and all
the people like oh huh like what
happened to well
oh they just they're a very poorly
managed company and it just it collapsed
like for months they have been talking
about trying to sell it or like trying
to have someone so nobody got their
money back nothing they're just like why
would you go with the airline called Wow
there's also while you that's not that
their service but it's also like wow I
don't have a flight yeah they're very
odd brand right now just to let you know
so feels like oh fly to so-and-so for 75
bucks it's like yeah that's a great deal
but you might die on that planet they
got famous because they had 60 yeah this
exceed all my flights Iceland Athena's
well that's so weird it's like I live in
Detroit I'm gonna go to one of the
coldest places on earth to go to the
other coldest place on earth yeah what
the [ __ ] is indefensible tip
indefensible like I said the only reason
why I'm gonna go there is to take
Instagram photos at the lagoon and then
I'm leaving immediately yeah mmm-hmm to
go there and to go on a tour for eight
hours of some [ __ ] and wearing a parkas
and [ __ ] no things can't do it I don't
blame you because I was very miserable
I like cold places cold the whole tile
is [ __ ] oh yeah we gonna what please
you know me so all the gear that all the
gear that we we bought and stuff it did
help is just that I didn't have the
proper gloves so my fingers were frozen
there were like leather gloves but they
weren't like instantly well I would too
but not for the real [ __ ] yeah what I
did buy gloves from North Face before
going but then I bought them too big so
I returned them and I forgot to get ones
that actually fit me and so that's what
happened with the gloves and then the
shoes that I bought their hiking shoes
they were amazing they were really
comfortable they were awesome but the
entire top part of it this whole thing
here was wool so what every time every
time we we had to step in puddle you get
waterproof ones you should have stuck
with the Nike woods but they didn't fit
me they were they actually hurt my feet
cold play antenna they were too tight on
the side that's for snow I know show me
pictures of her in Iceland right and
when you hold the photo for a second you
can see the video and she's gone and
she's like trying to hold a smile yeah
it's [ __ ] amazing my brother went to
Iceland with like his nurse buddies yeah
and he said he liked it for the first
day he goes he goes [ __ ] the food there
because people were mean to me really
nice it was really good so I was
surprised because I had always heard
that Iceland had shitty food but the
food that we ate was really good I don't
know but uh it was it tells me the
opposite cuz you know he's like into
food websites and everything is like
yeah everyone's talking about how
Iceland has like the best food and all
this stuff and I was like what that's
not what I heard but anyway it was
really cool it was really beautiful but
then after some time with just
everything kind of started blending like
all the waterfalls started looking the
same all the glaciers start looking the
same yeah but it was still gorgeous all
the glaciers look the same that's my
review I'm too
they should like color some of these
bases or something that's the most
sensitive right now
she can take them she could take a job
crying inside you enough just come back
from a place where you look the same
that's all the time we wore all the time
Geo have you seen the compilation vids
we wore all the time no II don't
oh yeah all the time laser I like that
you could really start your own and you
traveled so much no no no because like
every time I think about how much I've
traveled and then I think about old
Tiff's who like would die to travel I'm
just like whoa that's so crazy
that's what would you tell you all old
self to shut the [ __ ] up look at me now
[ __ ]
you looking to talk to some in the
mirror I know probably in Iceland she's
like what do you think now [ __ ] you
call it ass [ __ ]
you say the word [ __ ] it's so [ __ ]
fun the way you say [ __ ] I think this
may be because there's no like it's cuz
I have no right to say it I think as you
say like the widest way possible yeah I
think so when you wouldn't let me blow
off you stupid thumb I don't know or do
you do the way I do that [ __ ] the side
like a [ __ ] cuz my fingers are so
[ __ ] long it's a high school dick
strange anyway yeah they were a guy did
this to you hey babe come over here come
over here for a second come here girl
hey Dee
I know he's looking into the camera but
it looks like you're looking right at me
go when you watch this video later
you're gonna love that what my hands did
your love I don't watch our videos you
should never should skip to this moment
in this video 12 minutes and 35 seconds
tweeted sir the same at this exact
moment you tweets her Senator Jim
Senator Jeff I'll do it again I'll do it
again but anyway yes oh wow
they okay so other airlines like Iceland
air and other ones they were doing
rescue fares for these all so they were
giving him discounts but like that
family I was telling you about they said
it would cost $8,000 for the three of
them just a one-way just to get back
home
to get take it where do they live dude
[ __ ] Patagonia I said it and you
laughed at me for saying 353 nothing
there's nothing that can protect them
like you can sue the [ __ ] out of Wow no
no money they it even has much in their
claws like every airline you're [ __ ]
at every airline like they don't even
have to be on time you know that you you
wave all show that side and print [ __ ]
huh yeah you waive all your rights
you're not protected at all I heard of
another budget airline that they took
off 20 minutes early oh yeah guys a guy
mystic I missed a plane him and they
blamed him for coming
early enoguh bar yeah yeah they took off
early and then me and Joe were but it
was like a regular one I dealt our
American or whatever and they just took
off early and then and then they're like
I'm sorry the plane already took off and
then me and Joe looked out the window
like you mean that one it's right there
it's on the ground it'll snuff it took
off and they're like we can see it and
then I can't walk that but he's like
he's like oh oh yeah sure yeah no
problem sir
yeah because they're like their
loopholes like well we put on thing that
you should be there 45 minutes early
before your flavor ethic is [ __ ] you
whatever I'm cool just give me a voucher
and I'll chill videos Hotel vouchers
yeah that's bro Wow arey didn't give
anything to anyone no no doesn't existed
they were selling tickets up until the
morning that they collect Wow that's so
[ __ ] care for that I don't know I
think people can sue for the
class-action lawsuit for that now what
everyone's saying is just like hey then
if you booked it through your credit
card try to get your money back to your
credit card and we looked it through a
travel agency to try to get your money
back to them but you're pretty much
[ __ ]
geez you guys and being [ __ ] Iceland
is the worst [ __ ] yes again they went
to stay like four extra days and they
had to scramble to get a last-minute
hotel so that the cost went up for that
and then just food there's very another
so all of that [ __ ] it just went oh
that's expensive oh how much is a meal
that's like double here maybe there
she's expensive out there it is
expensive but I wouldn't say double like
like a meal here is like seven to ten
bucks how much you think it's on doing
edible what's the food what kind of food
is it cuz I'm imagining frozen fish and
jam no they oughta lamb they have a lot
of lamb fermented yeah fermented lard
ezio puppies they have normal food
[Music]